the gyro can experience what is the is
there an estimate of how many cartel
members are growing in this country
right now if you say there's 27 28
states is that what you say what is that
is there a rough estimate of how many
cartel members are here right now doing
this kind of shop this comes to it you
know it's it's a real approximation
because you only know based on who you
catch your graph enable a debrief but
like in California we know from the
amount of grows we deal with every year
just on the trespass you know cartel
front and the number of operatives it
takes to run a grow and get it started
and then to harvest it I mean a
conservative estimate ten thousand ten
thousand yeah I'd say conservatives
California just in California and the
reason we say that and I always go very
conservative because it's such a kind of
a silent enterprise and it's really hard
to get some of this data but we've we've
just validated it through the numbers of
things we run across you know when you
look at the fact that it takes two
skilled growers that are vetted because
they cut their teeth down to Mexico
doing it effectively under the federales
nose and they grow well and and and you
mentioned this one yet Mike Baker on the
show which was interesting and you hit
it on the head when you said man these
guys are really resourceful you know if
you got a respect their work ethic and
now and you have to because they're
they're hiking water line they're hiking
infrastructure in they're covering their
tracks they're out there for six months
at a time you see they were walking
around with carpet strapped to their
feet that didn't leave footprints
yeah and hid more especially we have a
whole lot of photos in that book about
things we've seen on trail cameras and
they will put felt lined lined soft felt
on their shoes tie them up tight and if
they're walking like an old Forest Road
you know this got a gravel base you'll
never see that track yeah I mean you
know you you've tracked big game I've
done it you know it's the same type of
technique and if you don't have any sign
I mean they're really good at disguising
and we actually found a guy and I have a
picture of this in the book and also in
the PowerPoint when I when I teach to
this throughout the country cow hooves
actually carved out of wood because a
couple years ago we were you know the US
Forest Service a lot of this grow
problem is on our national forests you
know Northern California and Northeast
in California not so much Silicon Valley
where I started but the rest of the
state even down here and what these guys
would do is there's cattle leases on
those properties where you know ranchers
can run cattle on part of the forest and
you know or a joint on private property
and we were getting tips on a bunch of
grows you know or you've seen them from
the air or hunter or angler would report
or we'd have a suspicion because of a
waterway or do we get see some plants
from satellite or whatever and we go try
to find this grow and when we're picking
up tracts and we're you know we were
pretty good at finding these things now
we've been trial and error in it for a
lot a lot of years but we're seeing a
lot of cattle tracks cuz we're running
around with cows and sure enough they
were putting on cow hooves and strapping
them on top or underneath their their
boots clomping around to disguise
themselves as cattle clever right and
then once they get way up into a deep
canyon where they're gonna put their
grow they just take them off and throw
them in a backpack and then the light
bulb went off we better look at you know
our tracks a little more carefully so
how do you guys try to go about finding
these things do you do you rely on
people reporting them or do you have
like aerial surveys but how do you it's
it's a mix of all of that we get a lot
of reports from people in the ground and
our best reporting parties or what we
call our peas are hunters and anglers
hmm when it comes to the outdoor public
but anyone in the outdoors could run
across some but hunters and anglers
especially because where do we go when
we're gonna find a good waterhole for
elk or you know we're hunting rock tail
we're gonna go you know we're not gonna
stay on the beaten path man we're gonna
go down to the headwaters we're gonna
find a pristine area we're going to get
away from people so all the people that
are going the deepest into the
backcountry absolutely absolutely and
then they're finding the water you know
source and they're maybe they're
following it and it's dry or it's
diverted like what I found in 2004 that
started this whole craziness and then
they run into a grow we also do find it
from the area you know we do all
agencies it's no no secret no no
tactical reveal we fly to look for this
stuff from the air I have a friend found
one on Tejon ranch really yeah yeah a
few years back and I didn't think
anything of it I thought it was just
some crazy person decided to try to grow
pot yes this back before was
recreationally legal okay
and there was no shootout or anything
crazy like that they got there after
yeah either they realized that their
grow-op had been compromised and they
took off but you know Tejon Ranch is
enormous it's like 270,000 acres yeah
and just the the gall of these guys to
go deep into that ranch and set up this
grow site right and the guys who work
there they I guess they just stumbled
upon it I think they stumbled upon it
because of garbage - if I remember
correctly yeah that that follows track
and the thing now you're talking about a
private hunting ranch it's got a cattle
lease and all that tones huge we've done
a lot of good stuff with tyonne Ranch
and supported you know good hunting
programs there but an interesting
statistic when I retired last year in
December in 2018 you know I mean we keep
stats ever since one of the cool things
about that our specialized team started
in 2013 is we solidified all the
documentation to be spot-on
you know reporting was kind of haphazard
throughout the state we weren't sure
what other agencies were doing but we
knew what we were doing now and so I'm
keeping that data and there was a real
shift in just public land presence of
these cartel growers and by the time I
retired last year it was almost a 50/50
split
so ranch is like town ranch a private
hunting Club in the Silicon Valley one
up in Shasta County so you know where
they're doing big-time conservation
projects to get Blacktail and mule deer
and tule elk and everything else up in
numbers and now they've got this
presence on their hunting Club hitting
one of their sensitive waterways you
know so so it's it's not just a public
land thing and it's really good for
everybody listening to know that you
could find it anywhere and you stumbled
on it and it's it's funny you mentioned
the reporting parties the cool thing
after I did Stevens show on a meat-eater
and talked to those guys we sort of get
tips you know I actually got a tip and
you know and it's it's in play and I
won't say too much more about it but
we'll Debbie we'll be talking when it's
all over and done but it's it's going to
get handled and not it's so cool to see
the guys like you and I that hunt and
love it and love the passion of what's
out there are out there stumbling on
this stuff and getting out safely and
and we're fired up enough not to wait
you know we're calling people to say hey
it's out there can you help us or it's
the warden sheriff's or